et aucun bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
ce soir vous êtes avocat au barreau de
paris et d'israël vous avez été de 1942
à 1944 un des responsables de la
résistance juive de 1983 à 1989 vous
avez été président du crif et votre
liberté de ton est bien connu c'est
pourquoi nous sommes heureux de vous
accueillir dans cette émission vous avez
82 ans voulait porter plutôt bien je
dois dire et vous ne cessé d'évoluer de
vous remettre en cause de remettre en
cause vos certitudes et de vous ouvrir
aux autres en 1988 vous avez écrit avec
hammadi et sid qui est secrétaire
général de la ligue arabe
un livre qui s'appelle de vérité en face
et qui était le premier dialogue
important entre deux personnalités
d'importance voilà et aujourd'hui vous
publiez manifeste d'un juif libre chez
liana levi qui est une plaidoirie pour
la paix au proche orient
[Musique]
vous dites théo klein il est temps que
les juifs 16 de craindre le monde qui
les entoure et 16 de recréer un ghetto
virtuel oui je crois que c'est un gros
problème
après deux mille cinq cents ans de
ghetto c'est difficile d'en sortir
alors c'est vrai qu'on en est sorti déjà
au moment de la révolution française on
n'y a pas tellement cru ou pas assez et
puis ça s'est fait lentement dans
d'autres pays et aujourd'hui encore
certains ont besoin de se convaincre que
nous sommes citoyens des citoyens comme
les ont nous avons le droit de nous
défendre en tant que citoyens nous avons
le droit d'être respectés en tant que
citoyen et je crois pas que nous ayons à
nous mettre à part dans cette affaire
mais je crois qu'il faut accepter de
lutter avec les autres après tout chaque
fois que nous avons été touchés les
autres ont été touchées ainsi hitler a
commencé par nous mais il a finalement
tué beaucoup de monde mais alors autant
alerté tout de suite autant à dire tout
de suite aux autres et bien écoutez ne
croyez pas que c'est pour nous seulement
méfiez-vous ça pourrait être pour vous
également à tout prix que les juifs sur
le peuple élu
j'en suis profondément persuadé mais ça
veut rien dire je veux dire je voudrais
expliquer pourquoi nous avons une chance
c'est que
depuis l'origine nous sommes porteurs
d'un livre les cinq livres de moïse que
nous appelons la torah c'est à dire
l'enseignement et je pense que ça c'est
un privilège on a été les premiers à
porter ce livre est ce livre a été le
premier à devenir universel
alors ça représente une certaine
responsabilité plus qu'un privilège
est ce que le communautarisme en ce
moment en france de la part de tout le
monde et pas seulement des juifs est ce
que ça vous inquiète
écoutez ce qui m'inquiète c'est le repli
sur soi
je crois qu'à notre époque nous devons
essayer avant tout de comprendre des
autres et de commencer par les respecter
j'ai tout à l'heure entendu un mot
tolérance
oui moi j'aime pas tellement de mots
tolérance parce que le tolérance à la
limite c'est admettre parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement mais respecté
c'est beaucoup plus important je crois
qu'il faut respecter les gens et vous ne
pouvez être respectable que si vous
respectez les autres
si eux mêmes ne se respectent pas le
problème est un peu différent mais vous
savez alors on peut même aller plus loin
c'est pas le respect seulement qu'il
faudrait c'est l'amour
mais c'est peut-être beaucoup demandé
que les juifs aiment les arabes mais que
les arabes aiment les juifs avec vous je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous pas
du tout de toute écoute mais je comptais
pour moi il faut que je supporte tomber
c'est beaucoup plus simple qu'on ne le
pense vous savez moi je me souviens
d'une époque où les
et les arabes les journalistes arabes et
les journalistes israéliens qu'ils
étaient interviewés dans les médias ici
ne voulais pas être dans la même pièce
mais quand après la séquence ils se
retrouvaient d'or eh bien il se
rassembler et discuter entre eux qu'ils
découvraient beaucoup de son sens commun
je moi je voulais aller comme ça
est ce qu'on peut vivre ensemble moi je
viens d'un pays qui est le maroc où il
ya des citoyens marocains chrétiens
juifs bien sûr musulmans on est arrivé à
vivre ensemble et le le roi mohamed 5
sept dernières paroles avant de mourir à
son fils donc tu as ça ne s'était occupe
toi de mai juifs
donc c'est qu'on peut le faire moi mais
les meilleurs amis mes parents étaient
juifs au maroc il n'ya jamais eu ne
serait-ce que le terme juif quand ils
avaient leur fait-on leaf était en même
temps que quand nous avions le ramadan
il ne vient en même temps nous et
c'était comme ça et c'est seulement en
arrivant en europe qu'on a cette
discrimination qui est terrible c'est à
dire sur un sale arabe qui à majorité
arabe
on n'a jamais entendu parler de ce terme
qui pour moi est affreux parce qu'on
parle d'individus et non pas de juifs ou
de musulmans de machin ou de choses et
comme quand on peut y arriver donc
pourquoi qu'on en arrive là c'est
difficile à expliquer mais comment dire
il ya des préjugés ça existe
il ya des conflits ça existe et en
europe il ya eu des conflits importants
il faudrait remonter très très loin et
peut-être se poser la question de savoir
si ce n'est pas parce que la source
commune du christianisme et du judaïsme
existait que il fallait se différencier
et puis il ya aussi le fait que les
religions deviennent des institutions et
que les institutions lutte pour le
pouvoir et qu'à un moment donné il faut
imposer ce pouvoir après tout on arrive
à une guerre des religions c'est quand
même c'est quand même stipulé avec les
catholiques adorait des juifs il voulait
simplement qu'il se convertisse avec les
musulmans reconnaissent donc moïse est
reconnue dans le coran jésus à la peine
issa a reconnu dans le coran et crise et
moussa ben oui c'est moussa et il ça
c'est jésus et les musulmans quand
mahomet a été viré de la mecque ou de
médine
ceux qui l'ont accueilli sont les juifs
c'est un peu disputées avec eux c'est un
petit peu mais on le reconnaît c'est à
dire que attendait le type comme qui
nous a sauvé la mise c'était quand même
le peuple juif
donc il ya un moment où c'est plutôt des
espèces de trucs techniques aux
politiques d'intérêt plutôt économique
que spirituelle ni et hyper machiste et
encore une fois si la connerie humaine
qui est venue se greffer là-dessus mais
quand vous lisez les textes on a
énormément de choses en commun nous
reconnaissons les dix commandements
lorsque vous prenez les dix
commandements ils sont valables dans
pour toutes les religions monothéistes
on a tous les mêmes points communs les
mêmes programmes ils sont valables
fortement c'est même pas une question de
religion c'est une question de civisme
c'est une question de choses que vous
vous devez adapter au jour le jour au
quotidien
je sais pas ne pas tromper sa femme
respecter les anciens
toutes ces choses là sont des choses de
base qu'on ne sait même pas une question
de religion c'est une question de savoir
vivre au quotidien avec l'autre elles
sont bien les animatrices de france 2
quand même non c'est pas n'importe quoi
bien
alors tu es aucun votre message
s'adresse également aux juifs d'israël à
qui vous dit comment pourrions nous
refuser plus longtemps aux palestiniens
ce à quoi ils aspirent
et ce à quoi nous avons nous même
aspirer oui je suis pas le premier à
dire ça non mais il ya un certain pierre
mendès-france qui a dit ça longtemps
avant moi et je pense qu'il avait
profondément raison au sujet des
problèmes que posent les colons juifs en
cisjordanie
vous vous demandez ce que deviendraient
les colons israéliens à l'intérieur d'un
état palestinien
et vous dites pourquoi pas des
palestiniens juifs comme il ya des
arabes israéliens finalement oui
pourquoi pas il y avait des juifs au
maroc il y en a encore il y en a un peu
partout
pourquoi pas lancer de partisans de deux
états une capitale jérusalem et j'ai
demandé de venir ce soir pour réagir sur
des choses qui ont été dites sur ce
plateau des choses qui sont
extraordinairement coco mutante qui ont
été dites à la fois par elie barnavi et
pas les lâcher
magnéto serge il faut faire l'europe au
proche orient
il faut que nous expliquions de
l'exemple européen pourrait pour faire
une confédération sur place et c'est ça
qui va se passer finalement fédération
avec israël et des pays amis à une
confédération entre israël et la
palestine
non mais bravo - c'était la jordanie si
vous regardez une carte c'est la logique
même c'est la logique géographique si
vous voulez et l'avenir appartient ça on
va pas une fédération je dis bien une
confédération
c'est à dire chaque état gardant sa
propre personnalité mais unis dans une
espèce de d'ensemble vers marché
colombien du marché comme un plus
ce sont deux peuples qui par boudiaf et
se ressemblent nouveaux qui sont dans un
territoire très exigu qui sont les
voisins du liban de l'egypte de la
jordanie
j'imagine très bien que deux étapes
peuvent vivre côte à côte chacun ayant
le soutien aussi de son environnement
naturel donc nous on aura le soutien
aussi des états arabes
mais un jour je peux imaginer tout à
fait comme l'europe une confédération
une fédération d'états qui permettra
finalement israël aussi de se retrouver
dans un environnement cordiale qui la
reconnaît avec qu'elle peut faire
un du commerce des échanges que vous
dites c'est ce que disait elie barnavi
ici donc c'est donc noël paix ne veut
pas jeter les juifs à la mer
absolument pas elle n'a jamais voulu
voilà j'étais mis dans ma vie
ambassadeur d'israël et les mairies
représentants de rester en france
formidable ils ont ils ont dit les mêmes
choses à quelques semaines d'intervalle
coûté je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
chacun des deux j'aime beaucoup l'île
achahid la vérité c'est que je la
préfère dans les conversations privées
plutôt que dans les débats publics
parce que là elle est un peu dangereuse
mais je crois qu'elle est très sincère
dans ce qu'elle a dit je suis persuadé
que elle le pense personnellement je
suis pas sûr que l'ol paie toujours
penser ça mais enfin peu importe on peut
douter d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il ya énormément de
palestiniens qui sont d'accord sur cette
position et je prends qu'il ya
énormément de palestiniens avec lesquels
il est possible de parler je dirais avec
deux têtes une certaine présomption est
peut-être un certain culot que parmi
ceux avec lesquels on peut parler il y
en a qui s'appelle marwan barghouti et
qui sont ce moment et pas un jeu les
israéliens mais dans une position
désagréable il est en prison
est ce que vous êtes pour sa libération
je souhaite qu'il soit libéré parce que
je pense que c'est quelqu'un avec lequel
le dialogue est possible
c'est en quelques jours la nouvelle
décision c'est le 2 janvier donc on
verra ce qui est décidée par la justice
israélienne les palestiniens ne sont pas
nos ennemis ce sont nos voisins c'est
pas la même chose fait du bien
d'entendre des choses que le fun
1 est ce que vous croyez théo klein que
la guerre d'irak sera une bonne ou une
mauvaise chose pour israël
le problème n'est pas de vaincre l'irak
le problème se pose tout de suite après
qu'est ce qui va se passer
est ce qu'il y a en irak des forces
prête à organiser ce pays où est ce que
les américains vont s'installer là bas
et à ce moment là de quoi s'agit-il
d'une nouvelle aventure et d'une
nouvelle aventure coloniale
je prends pas que
et je crains que les américains n'est
pas un plan qui aille jusqu'au bout de
l'action qu'ils veulent entreprendre
alors le moyen orient l'irak la montée
du fondamentalisme islamiste
on a parlé dans tout le monde en parle
[Musique]
latifa bonsoir je suis bon soir
interview vérité
en
alors le 27 septembre 1996 les talibans
entre dans le câble houle
les écoles sont fermées les femmes sont
humiliés insultés enfermé est obligé de
porter ce que vous portez ce soir c'est
à dire le tchadri 27 septembre c'est
vrai que c'était le jour qu'il a basculé
l'avis de toutes les femmes à cabo
toutes les jeunes filles et cette ville
est devenue une ville en deuil
du jour au lendemain et moi j'étais plus
là latifa de la veille et j'ai changé en
un jour effectivement comme toutes les
jeunes filles 27 septembre 96 alors les
femmes ne peuvent plus sortir sans être
revêtue du tchad riz et sans être
accompagnées d'un homme
oui alors imaginez la charge de toutes
ces veuves qui depuis 18 années de
guerre parce qu'avant les talibans y
avait dix huit années de guerre qui
n'avaient pas d'homme et qui n'avait pas
de mari ou pas de frère avait perdu
imaginer le sort de ces femmes à quel
point elle se faisait humilier alors
fini le maquillage fini le rouge à
lèvres fini le vernis à ongles et si on
porte du vernis à ongles on peut avoir
les doigts coupés
c'était un dd des histoires rapportées
par une de mes amies proches je l'avais
vu justement les doigts coupés de cette
femme
latifa aujourd'hui des gens en france
vous regardez gens à l'étranger vous
regarde dans beaucoup de pays du monde
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui vous
regardent
prends moi je suis un africain dès lors
dire que jusqu'à jusqu'à quand ce
silence cette indifférence contre la
femme variable qui aujourd'hui souffrent
là-bas la fin de morgane c'est une femme
aussi comme n'importe quelle femme dans
le monde si un jour ce sort vous touche
ça m'étonnerait que vous acceptiez ce
sort ligh je pense que vous serez bien
contente en soit toutes les femmes dans
le monde vient de vous aider pour lever
la tête et moment vous relevé la tête
vous entendez un impact d'une violence
inouïe et trois secondes plus tard vous
voyez passer par la fenêtre devant vous
oui les débris débutera elle vous voyez
ci médusés je vois passer devant devant
mes fenêtres et de et mes employés sont
médusés aussi on voit passer des tonnes
d'oeufs de morceaux de ferraille de
kérosène de verre et on sait pas ce que
c'est vous prenez l'escalier assez
tranquillement au bout d'un moment il ya
47 étages à descendre évidemment la
descente la durée 50 minutes vous
arrivez sur le parvis du wall trade
center oui je suis sorti en souterrain
les gens qui sont sortis sur le parvis
et qui était parti en même temps que moi
eux sont décédés donc je suis sorti en
souterrain en sortant dans la rue je me
suis retourné j'ai vu ce bâtiment en feu
là j'ai compris que c'était très grave
effectivement je me suis retourné une
deuxième fois et je n'ai pas vu ce que
ce monstre kim qui arrivait sur nous le
nuage tueur le killer cloud le nuage ce
tueur est ce que j'appellerais plus tard
aussi vraiment le baiser de la mort
c'est parce que ça dépasse l'entendement
en un instant alors que dans cette rue
il y avait une vie extraordinaire de
services de secours il était dans tous
les sens de voitures de d'ambulances de
gyrophares partout de sirène soudain
s'abat sur nous cette masse monstrueuse
et tout devient silencieux
et un avion qui rentre dans la plus
grande tour du monde c'est irrationnel
quoi tu vois quand qu'encore
l'irrationnel smea chez ses c'est
horrible c'est aberrant n'y a pas de
mots toutes les formes de terrorisme
je condamne à mort moi je veux enfin les
couches condamné à mort je veux dire par
là que c'est ccc
j'arrive pas à trouver mes mots
tellement ça me semble déplacée mais je
te rassure mais
je crois que là on a décidé de d'akouda
les exterminer tous les terroristes mais
c'est pas en exterminant les terroristes
qu'on va arrêter le terrorisme c'est
justement on extermine les terroristes
pour fabriquer terrorisme voix sinon
l'algérie aurait plu déplu plus
d'incidence qui valurent est non moi
j'ai pas la solution je n'ai pas la
science infuse
simplement je crois que la solution est
politique qui voient la solution est la
politique c'est quoi c'est c'est sait
comment vivre ensemble qu'on va partager
le pas comment partager l'eau arrêté
d'humilier les gens tu vois je
tout ce que je peux dire en tout cas
c'est que ça va être difficile d'être
arabe c'est embêtant c'est tout alors le
13 septembre 2001 vous roulez sur le
plateau de milo entre mende et
montpellier c'est jeudi
la semaine est finie la nuit tombe vous
écouter la radio france info
hélas dans l'immensité des cévennes vous
entendez une voix qui dit votre nom
moussaoui où elle dit zacarias moussaoui
franco algérien a été arrêté en relation
avec les attentats du 11 septembre
on peut pas remplacer l'éducation c'est
c'est irremplaçable c'est une nécessité
moi je suis enseignant moi je veux le
bien moi je veux que les jeunes que je
forme au lycée ben ils soient utiles
pour eux mêmes pour leurs familles pour
la société j'ai pas envie qu'il se
laisse embrigadé par un groupe
extrémiste qui se passe sautée ou qui
tuent des gens et je voudrais que les
gens de bonne volonté
eh ben ils se révoltent eux aussi dans
quel sens mais qu'on sache que derrière
l'idéologie de la haine et la terreur ya
le wahhabisme ya l'idéologie de seuils
trop toub et qu'il ya des gens qui ont
de l'argent et qui pousse cela voilà
c'était donc l'islamisme dont tout le
monde en parle ça vous inspire quoi théo
klein ces quelques images que je viens
d'en temps m'inspire une sympathie très
profond ne se trouve que ce garçon est
extrêmement intelligent et tous les mots
qu'il prononce sont valables
il a vraiment une réflexion sur cette
affaire qui je me sens proche de lui ces
mots là justement est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ce sont les mots de la
majorité des musulmans de france et que
ça n'a rien à voir avec les intégristes
voilà ce qui m'a un peu quand on quand
j'entendais djamel parler des évènements
du 11 septembre
moi j'étais en studio on avait les
images qui tombait comme ça on dirait
que j'avais mes parents qui étaient de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée et je
les appelais en disant il montre quoi à
la télévision marocaine parce que
c'était ça lui c'est la guerre mondiale
tout va exploser on va repartir avec une
valise monsieur que je me suis imaginé
le scénario va vraiment catastrophe et
ma mère me dit écoute on a regardé la
télévision marocaine
le roi a condamné ces gestes on a
regardé la libye ils ont été condamnés
toute la majorité des chaînes arabes ont
condamné les faits du 11 septembre
à aucun moment on a montré les
témoignages de dirigeants de ces pays là
sur les chaînes françaises veulent
montrer qu'ils condamnaient et à partir
de ce moment là j'ai compris qu'ici même
en france on faisait le procès du
musulman et non pas de l'intégriste et
je pense à un truc c'est pas top of the
pops qu'il fallait qui vous filent ces
mots croisés sur france 2 au clair le
mot de la fin je crois qu'il est
important pour tout individu qui pensent
et qui envient n'ont pas de d'exercer
une influence mais de participer à la
vie commune il faut qu'il s'exprime et
qui s'expriment librement et il n'y a
pas de barrière à ce moment c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire ici merci en tous
les cas d'avoir été avec la fia
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu